hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to 4 Horsemen of the
Apocalypse the amnesia custom story that
is delightful in every way
Donnie box sevens happy to see you and
I'm happy to keep going in this game I
have actually not stopped recording
since I started it mechanical lubricant
well that sounds just delightful but
what fun activity are we're gonna be
doing with that I'm assuming we're gonna
be looping up this machine here oh no
that's what I'm gonna use to get back ah
gotcha gotcha gotcha [ __ ]
okay so ah oh how quaint how delightful
and how quaint so those were the
machines that I heard before and this
Lube is gonna ease up this wheel here so
that it confused why was that what what
why was that moving I've learned to not
trust anything so I'm assuming that
everything from watching you guys please
don't
who the hell are you huh oh oh not you
sorry I thought I heard a lady you keep
on being dead that definitely wasn't
Katherine I'm not art is this art er
sorry did i disturb your sleep
tailors what happens if I take him back
there's great opportunity what does that
mean
I just took him back there's someone
gonna be mad at me
someone's gonna be very mad someone's
going to be very hello sorry I took it
back it's like having a quarter on a
string at a vending machine that don't
work no more but he used to back in old
Popeye times whatever then was 1940s
what is that sound
I don't know what the hell I'm talking
about most of the time soon
most of these times when I just record
these things I just ramble on till
something happens to me something
horrible I take this oh it's a piece of
a war orb good I'm gonna wrap it up in
twine and make it whole once again just
like the marker from dead space I'm
going to make us all a home and why
should I trust you
uh in what way would you prove it to me
slightly seductive sounding lady man
awesome I roll dough which you know
voices can't tell gender maybe okay I'm
gonna be on my way I think I have
everything I need
do I don't know maybe yes no I don't
know
okay I'm gone goodbye goodbye sorry for
taking back the sailors not really go to
hell okay bye but stabby guy I'm out of
here I'm gonna make myself a heart
all right sorry walked out on someone
llegué boogie
it's the Deuter it's the dude yeah you
can cleave a door with one fell swoop
I sure hope future horror games don't
incorporate me actually shouting into
the microphone for these because
everything would know exactly where I
was know why that's why why that way why
would you go that way of always you
could have gone
why did you okay you're smart ancient
kid you filled with brain power come out
here
you catch me I got you I gotta get you
okay he's not behind me he's not
directly by any close it how do they
close that I don't know screw it
I'm here oh come on this isn't it y-yo
oh oh oh the forge here okay I can use
this to melt down the orbs using the
Forge because that seems like a smart
thing to do we can't use this item this
way ah come on
Oh for me how do I do this thing that
you do there we go
okay it automatically did the thing that
I did if I melted orb cuz smart cuz very
smart and this makes sense I did I did
it it's blood red yay like the blood of
the Fallen my favorite type of blood I
guess placing his belongings on the
table in front he looked over it where
she once lay empty was the room but not
through his eyes I read that before I
forgot that's the sound of
accomplishment someone up there really
knows how good I'm doing in this game if
you know what I mean yeah I don't know
who that lady thinks she was but she
obviously did not know what was best for
me
perhaps she did I got this weird feeling
that the story's gonna take a weird turn
considering that the daughter who I'm
almost positive just an imagination in
my head is telling me to stop the
horseman
lady is telling me not to do you know
for a place of famine there sure is a
lot of food here may be rotten but still
food I guess I guess you can't build a
level that just oh there's no food in
this level
ergo famine that would be like every
level in you all right let's see what
you got so someone has messed up the
door filing floor time you never mind
hello don't tell me this is them
okay that's your ding dong don't tell me
that shut up I'm trying to talk here
don't tell me that this is the mannequin
level hang on before I go through there
I just need to make sure there wasn't
anything else over here that I missed I
hate you guys
I hate you I hate mannequins oh hey Tom
I haven't actually played a game that
plays on my mannequin fears for a long
time it seriously has been a while so
I'm actually kind of hold full o moose
man's back with a vengeance he missed
out on me last time on the orders of
that lady person thing whoever was sorry
to me whoever may or may not have been
talking I'm gonna hide under the stairs
because it seems like a good thing to do
there a secret under here well I broke
that okay you didn't hear a damn thing
shut up you don't know what you're
talking about
you don't know what you're moaning about
oh this one needs some persuading never
mind it's not going anywhere actually
about this one no about you know you I'm
not even supposed to be down here was
this a place where I'm supposed to be
I've got no mama big baby okay really
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute this
seems like something I should be able to
go through but I can't get through it
seems like it was very intentionally
purpose-built for me to go through here
all of these boxes and all of these
things perfectly balanced in every way
it should have been obvious well this
guy's in here isn't he
stop just pacing back and forth you dick
okay I dropped that one haha oh very far
very okay hi
well now that we're meeting face to face
I thought I'd tell you some things
you're in douchebag
come on me bro ain't gonna give me I'm
too quick hop I'm too quick
I'm Allegiant a wild goose chase the
likes of which you've never seen
Oh
me
oh yeah okay okay okay all right so long
as we're out or anything bad happens to
me Hello Kitty like Joe Jesus give it up
man what he was it was it was it
don't yell he looks god you're so close
to me I almost touched your bun-buns yes
where was it where's it my ol arena oh
crap Oh poopy
oh he's not by me is he
OOP okay not ready to Kirk hoes dammit
closed why isn't it closing why the hell
is it a closed egg well there's been a
fun experiment in how to screw it
yourself over this but if I had any
personal preference in this situation I
would opt to not die need to not waste
oil that's what I need to not do
peekaboo eyes there yep he is there
that's exactly where he is I need to get
in that room cuz I need to do some
things so you know don't hate you he's
kinda in my way what the hell do I do
there's got a run by him again you
didn't say nothing
oh god damn it why do I keep trying to
press my luck I know it's not gonna work
ahhh
alright then take two oh good I'm all
the way back in the beginning I hope it
spawns him again that'll be fun
okay here we go what's up here anything
anything for me no a bunch of lies I was
totally pointless in a waste of
everybody's time sorry about that I'm
dumb that's okay I forgive you uh tiny
box Jimmy had a little coffee so uh he's
a little loopy don't mind I just filled
that up okay I put that out by manually
okay by manually let's see what was
actually in here for running through in
a blind panic anything important
anything pertinent to the story and or
my progress through this place has
anybody seen a giant ball
one really big ball probably gonna be
either gray or white or something like
that a blue maybe I guess I could've
hidden there wait a min what that do oh
damn it I heard tick ticking well I
didn't get anything we've what did that
open oh I get it opened at the end of
hallway okay I got it I got it was a
portcullis at the end of the hallway
okay go whoa whoa whoa whoa gonna slide
my way under there no no no no no no no
don't Tommy enough no no no got it yeah
I got it I'm the best all right good for
me oh hello how are you doing you look
good
are those your skulls mind if I take one
so I ain't kill very much ever mind I'm
gonna go through here the horsemen
defend their realm with the greatest
weapon of all their victims own mind
which is probably what's happening to me
right now
I mean torture I'm being manipulated to
do someone else just bidding maybe I did
go psycho and what the hell is going on
over there
you know I can't resist the sound of
slapping around I see a shadow pass over
me those weird
Oh someone wants some privacy huh too
bad I'm here to interrupt you cake
that's a lot of bread so I'm guessing
famine means that he took all the food
it won't give it to anybody else did
anybody lose a broomstick then so there
was nothing there was nothing in here
bread basket two points [ __ ] won't try
huh damn it broom [ __ ]
I'm all out of bread I lost all my
chances okay
so there's nothing here all right then
moving on there's no point to that it
was just wasting my oil over and over
and over need a key
gosh Dan what excited pardon okay thank
you
goddamn it is dark I'm gonna find a key
okay that is also new ambience
well that didn't make any sense
why'd you do that was that oh god it's a
torture thing isn't it
sack of potatoes oh oh I just threw a
sack of potatoes oh I just threw them
I'll be back red goes over here sure
I accept my sacrifice yay
someone really liked that tasted bread
and where'd my sack of potatoes go um
excuse me where the hell did my potatoes
go uh okay
oh here they are didn't I leave no what
what do you want for me answer me
yeah let me stop wasting my own oil here
Thank You Katherine I'm sure that's
actually you definitely not anything
weird I did I'm the best whoa good thing
I got out of there all right so what do
you want meat I don't have any meat I
could grab one of these rats broom say
broom bag of fruit how am I supposed to
know what the difference between a bag
of fruit and a sack of potatoes do you
want you guys want a broom
I got a broom I got a nice tasty broom
here for you
how about that
one thing you like that I go down there
apparently not okay well then
moving right along with the famine and
pestilence is of course but where am I
going to get meat where am I gonna get
where can I get meat do I have to
sacrifice a body part of me there
anything in here remember anything being
there I remember there being any meats
around here least I got a sack of fruit
no matter how old and decomposed it may
be I got it so that's some hush up
hey now where the hell am I gonna get
meat I'm gonna guess it has to be human
meat doesn't matter what khana meat it
is long as it's oh wait a minute where
did you come from
I have fight unknown I was just thrown
your right in I didn't know you were
there
well zzzz if it was gonna be that easy I
wouldn't look around for so long oh well
let me through your gate hey what okay
there we go just need to double-check
the meat was digested properly I got it
yeah and I got a key everything is going
beautifully over here nothing bad could
possibly happen to me I'm going to be
just fine I'm not good
oh boy whoa hey whoa you wanna come down
there
moose man man got three orbs can't stop
me after seeing a brief life again he
felt warmth within him hope was the only
thing he had to hold on for does that
mean she's not dead
wait a minute what's going on here
something doesn't make sense
quite of the understanding of what
you're talking about but this is a
different area so I got a wooden crank
that's good so what does that mean for
me am I ever gonna return all this food
to the starving children of the world
oh god it's one of these come on I'm
moving my mouse in all directions here
all right you're gonna be tricky like
that huh tricky dick tricky dick trap
door huh you're not gonna open for me
huh oh don't matter which way I move my
mouse oh you were always there we go
no is that of a [ __ ] oh this was the
thing I knew it oh where you going man
yeah that's so huh
too bad I'm out of here whoa boy don't
come this way bro
it's got to get down to the end of
hallway turn the crank and I'll be good
I'm good I'm good I'm solid
oh here's the turn crank doing it that's
what that was for okay here we go all
right we're good it's so good
we are the goodest of the good we're
good all righty then doing great guys
we're doing good and I've just run out
of oil even better yay hahaha well it
was my name I forget what my name was I
know our turn is the other guy in here
but I don't know what my name is okay
only one more place to go then huh death
one the least friendly of them all oh
this looks fun I really need to be
careful about my ol because I'm gonna
run out over here hey about this one's
gonna be delightful filled with women
vigor and hope and promise and dreams
and nightmares and also dreams oh just
more bodies reminds me of that scene
from Mass Effect 3 y'all know the one
I'm talking about whoo they sure do love
the process that guys having a good old
time I guess and I wonder how many
bodies actually made for him these are
just dead bodies can't possibly have
another NPC anywhere just more dead
bodies it is duck
Oh what you got an upset stomach there
buddy oh no you are not gonna do okay
that's right you better open up for me
I'm gonna go down into this dark paedon
oh where am I
why did I come down here oh oh listen
this was dumb of me oh god why oh don't
tell me I need to find something in here
oh shut up
you don't need to worry about me I'm
here in the death Oh already got
problems there's so many naked butts how
many dead naked butts wait was that
another shot up okay
oh I'm just supposed to stay down here
until he goes away I get it I get it I
get it
I was longer do I have to sit in the
putrid remains of all these people I
don't know that'd be all clear
hi good another quick glance at the
butts stick that in my memory forever as
I make my way back up okay okay
everything's good in this neighborhood
I'm gonna be traumatized for life if I
do get out of here but if I don't then I
don't need to worry about it
it's all good oh good I miss tiny bug
stem buddy right here yeah okay so
anyway Donny but I just wanted to make
that very clear
raggedy cranky cranked cranky cranked
Franchitti crank okay else one good
thing I did that
another broom is it's literally a broom
closet I don't even have those anymore
oh good more butts
let me just like those up that's the
best I've seen yet the butt choir of the
underworld what was the point of going
down there
was it just to sit there and wait until
the guy goes away you know this whole
death realm I think he takes things well
too seriously I mean all the other
things eventually lead to death but God
why is this guy
well that's stuck I need some more
mechanical lube maybe the blood of these
fellows nevermind I'm going away it's
just II got the worst guy I hate that
guy so damn much
the goddamn noise with you Oh what's
with the crying of the babies that's all
combined there's some horrible
amalgamation of lifts all right
don't chop my head off thank you come on
you're stuck and let me turn this on you
won't move ah I didn't realize that's
exactly what I needed
I don't really realize a lot of things
about what's going on right here
small boxes not tiny enough hmm so I did
a thing I don't exactly know what the
thing I did was but I did it
please tell me I don't have to run into
that guy again the suitor how didn't
even have a cute name for him he's just
a dick Oh again with the crying of the
children it's bad
I know I've probably done horrible
things in my life maybe I'm not actually
stopping the apocalypse maybe I'm just
in hell
okay thank you maybe I'm gonna be
swimming in an ocean of blood and then a
blood water monitor is gonna come
rushing out for me if that made any
sense at all give you five hours more
skulls more bones or everything
another broom oh god I'm so strong oh I
wish I was less amazing huh all right
okay can I climb up in that tree house
and I won't have to deal with all these
dead bodies oh good only one bone
exactly as good as what I needed yes
okay can you please just coordinate your
self to not be so derpy thank you after
waiting for numerous hours within the
hub room I decided to explore into the
death Quarter if you're reading this
then you probably learned for yourself
that this was a bad decision there are
indescribable things in this area
earlier someone something ran at me from
the darkness and I was forced to run for
my life I kept running and running
closing doors behind me eventually I
found a hatch in the floor I opened it
and descended into the floor below
though it was a safe place to my horror
I learnt that I was in fact hidden
amongst dead rotten corpses the first
clue was the smell normally it would
have been too much but in this instance
I had to endure it the second clue was
the soft spongy floor on which I stood
finally I turned on a lantern to my
horror as the faces of the dead stared
up at me I was down there for about an
hour when I decided to take my chances
by returning to the upper level when I
emerged from the cellar the area was
empty in silent I saw my opportunity and
made my way through the rest of the
corridors as quickly as possible
now I'm resting in this raised alcove it
seems to be safer up here as I can watch
for the creatures below should they
appear a few have walked past me but I
kept quiet until they pass I have to
keep moving for now so who is this art
or guy is he me and I'm just doing this
over and over again is that the lesson
I'm learning here but either way I'll
find out the mystery in the next episode
because I'm all out of time
so thank you all so much for watching
and remember the description contains a
wealth of Let's Plays I've done of all
the various custom stories and the
original and machine for pigs so check
them out in your leisure and thank you
again everybody for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye your piano playing
what are you talking about
you dog I wish you when I'm over there